عوده الى تسليحه اوكرانيا ومعاناه
الولايات المتحده من نفادي الذخيره
المتطوره التي يمكن نقلها الى كياب فما هو
الحل
مستودعات للمعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
اقامتها واشنطن في اسرائيل قبل عقود
لاستخدامها في حاله الطوارئ اتفق
البنتاجون مع الجانب الاسرائيلي في ظل
حكومه السابقه على نقل بعض من هذه الذخيره
لكيف تقول انه بمقتضى الاتفاق نقل الى
اوكرانيا نحو 300,000 قذيفه مدفعيه من
عيار 100 و55 ملم وجاء في التقرير الصحيفه
ان نحو نصف القذائف التي تم شحنها الى
اوروبا تمهيدا لتسليمها في النهايه
لاوكرانيا عبر بولندا انا ويستخدم الجيش
الاوكراني حوالي 90,000 طلقت مدفعيه شهريا
اي ضعف ما تنتجه الولايات المتحده واورو
اوروبا مجتمعه
كانت اسرائيل قد رفضت طيله الفتره الحرب
ااا تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه خوفا من تضرر
علاقاتها مع روسيا لكن المسؤولين
الامريكيين لاسراء العسكريين عفوا
الاسرائيليين وافقوا على خطه نقل الذخائر
الامريكيه لتجنب التوتر مع واشنطن بحسب
نيويورك تايمز وتعود اصول مخزون المعدات
والذخائر العسكريه الامريكيه في اسرائيل
الى حرب اكتوبر عام 73 حينما نقلت
الولايات المتحده جوا اسلحه لامداد القوه
الاسرائيليه
وبعد الحرب تم انشاءه مخازن حرب او
مستودعات ذخيره امريكيه في اسرائيل
لاستخدامها في حال اندلاع ازمه الازمه
مستقبلا ولم يسمح لاسرائيل باستخدام هذا
المخزون الا خلال الحرب على لبنان عام
2006 او الحرب على قطاع غزه عام 2014
ووفقا لتقرير صادر عن الكونجرس في فبراير
شباط الماضي
بطبيعه الحال تقوم الولايات المتحده
باعاده ملا مخزون في مستودعات الذخيره
الامريكيه باسرائيل بصوره دائمه وتنقل
رويترز عن ديفيد ايفري وهو مدير عام سابقي
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه وجنرال سابق في
القوات الجويه قوله انه على الرغم من ان
هذه الامدادات في اسرائيل فان الامريكيين
لا يحتاجون الى ابن ل- نقلها فهي ممتلكات
امريكيه
للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع الينا من واشنطن
لاري كورب وهو مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق وكبير الباحثين في مركز التقدم
الامريكي سيذكر هل اللجوء الى هذا المخزون
الاستراتيجي في اسرائيل معناه ان واشنطن
تعاني عجزا في تزويد اوكرانيا مع تطور
الحرب بهذه الذخائر
لهذه الذخيره في اوكرانيا ضد القوات
الروسيه بالتاكيد لان الحرب استمر بما
توقعناها فان الولايات المتحده قد استمتدت
امداداتها
وتريد ان تبقي هذه الامدادات مستمره ايضا
هذا الحال مع الحلفاء بالتالي مثلا في
اسرائيل وهي كوريا الجنوبيه ايضا لدينا
مخازن للاسلحه لاننا قلقون ايضا مثلا من
هجومي كوريا الشماليه بالتالي تقوم بارسال
هذه
الاخيره الى اوكرانيا لكي تستمر في يمكن
ان نراه ربما هجوم ربيعي واذا ما تمكن
واذا ما حصل ذلك
ويلهن وبالتالي ماذا عن الحسابات
الامريكيه ما يتعلق بالذقائر ان طالت
الحرب
وكما رايت راينا اليوم ان هذه الذخيره
لدينا مخزن اخرى كما قلت في كوريا
الجنوبيه من اجل تعويض ما يتم استخدامه
لكننا لا نريد ان نستنفذ مخزوننا ربما الى
مكان هنالك حاله حرب مثلا ضد الصين او اي
بلد اخر نقوم باستبدال ذخائر التي همم قام
الكثير من حلفائنا بتوزيد بتزويدها
اوكرانيا ومن هذا امر مدير الاهتمام لانه
لحد الان اسرائيل تحاول ان تبقى خارجه هذه
الحرب لا تبدو وكانها هي معاديه لروسيا
هل اسرائيل بشكل او باخر
تدخل في الحسابات باستعمل هذا المخزون
الذي هو على اراضيها
ان اسرائيل لا يمكنها ان تقام عندما تكون
تطلب الولايات المتحده ان تقوم به لانها
مجهز اساسي للاسلحه لاسرائيل وحسب الاتفاق
في عام 1973 بين اسرائيل ومصر بشكل اساسي
هذا يعني ايضا انه
اردنا انهاء هذه الحرب باسرع وقت ممكن كما
ذكرت سابقا هذا الامر يضع اسرائيل في موقف
صعب لاننا نريد ان تبقى الموقف الحياله
لكن عندما نظرنا الى حقيقه ان ايران وهي
التي تراها اسرائيل تهديد هي تساعده روسيا
لربما همم لم تقاوم اسرائيل طلب الولايات
المتحده الاخيره
ماذا لو كان الوضع يختلف اي كان الاتفاق
او ما تم الان مع الحكومه الحاليه
هل سيتم بنفس الطريقه
اذا ما اخذنا بالنظر الاعتبار التوتر بين
نتنياهو والولايات المتحده لكن كلا اعتقد
ان الامر يظهر يظهر بشكل اساسي ان
الاسرائيلينا يعرفون حتى لو اختلفوا حول
كيفيه استخدامه هذه الذخيره باخذ من نظر
الاعتبار انهم يعتمدون بشكل كبير على
الولايات المتحده بسبب الاتفاق الذي
ابرمناه في عام 1973 ونستمر
وما يحتاجونه للدفاع انفسهم ليس امامهم
خيار سوى ان يتماشوا مع طلب الولايات
المتحده لكن النقطه المهمه اننا لا نرى
اسرائيل يقومون علنا بالشكوى ضد هذا الامر
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق وكبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي شكرا
جزيلا لك